[ LAUGHS ]
THREE, TWO, ONE.
YEAH!
Jesse:
THIS ISN'T SOUNDING GOOD.
[ LAUGHS ]
OH!
WHOA,
IT SOUNDS TERRIBLE.
Rachel: THIS IS AWESOME.
OH, YEAH!
I'M AMAZED AT HOW
MUCH CONTROL I HAVE.
WE WERE ALMOST DRIFTING.
YES!
OUR TAPE IS ON FIRE!
OKAY,
HERE COMES THE DRIFT.
OH, GOD.
SO I WAS LIKE, "OH, MY GOODNESS.
I HOPE WE DON'T CRASH."
WHOA!
WE NEARLY
TOOK THE CONE OUT.
THERE WE GO.
WHEN I WAS DRIVING,
THE RIDE WAS A LITTLE BUMPY,
BUT THE TIRES HELD UP
PRETTY WELL.
WOW, I CAN SEE THINGS
FLYING ALL THE WAY OFF OF US.
-WHOA!
-I SMELL DUCT TAPE.
AS FAR AS ADAM DRIVING,
THOSE ARE DEFINITELY
EXTREME CONDITIONS.
[ ALL SHOUTING ]
YEAH!
WHOO!
[ LAUGHTER ]
COME ON! COME ON,
WE CAN MAKE IT. YES!
YEAH!
Cannan: YEAH!
WHOA!
I THINK WE HAVE
SOME PROBLEMS.
HOUSTON.
-HOUSTON, WE HAVE A PROBLEM.
I THINK I COULD FEEL
SOME SPECIFIC ISSUES.
Narrator: AND THAT IS WHY
WE CAN'T HAVE NICE THINGS.
DUDES, GIVE ME SOME!
THAT WAS SO MUCH FUN!
DESPITE ADAM'S INEVITABLE NEED
TO PUSH THE DUCT TAPE
TIRES BEYOND EVEN THEIR
PRODIGIOUS CAPABILITIES,
THE RESULT'S CLEAR CUT.
AFTER ADAM'S RIDE,
THE TIRES WERE TRASH.
BUT IF I GOT A FLAT,
AND I HAD A WHOLE BUNCH OF ROLLS
OF DUCT TAPE IN MY TRUNK,
AND A LOT OF TIME,
I THINK I COULD
DEFINITELY MAKE A TIRE.
Jesse:
ADAM, THIS TIRE IS GONE.
-REALLY?
-ABSOLUTELY GONE.
[ LAUGHS ]
-THAT'S WHAT WE WERE FEELING.
-YOU DESTROYED THESE THINGS.
I DID.
LOOK AT THE ONE OVER HERE.
THIS WAS ONE'S ALSO
SEEN BETTER DAYS,
INCLUDING THIS MORNING.
OVERALL, I'M REALLY
SURPRISED HOW GOOD
THESE DUCT TAPE TIRES
ACTUALLY HELD UP.
Adam: COME ON, COME ON.
WE CAN MAKE IT, YES!
IN THE GREAT DUCT TAPE
MYTHBUSTERS TRADITION,
CAN YOU BUILD A DUCT TAPE TIRE?
THERE'S NO DOUBT
IN MY MIND THAT YOU CAN.
IS CANNAN A BETTER
DRIVER THAN ADAM?
THAT'S PLAUSIBLE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO SHOULD WE CALL IT
THE MYTH,
THAT DUCT TAPE CAN MAKE
A VIABLE TIRE IN A PINCH?
-YEP.
-YES.
I FEEL LIKE
IT'S TOTALLY CONFIRMED.
-CONFIRMED.
-ABSOLUTELY.
CONFIRMED!